ah what a lovely and nice fellow ah yeah
Tammy tell me what he did you every time
Tammy you bottles schmuck I know you
were Satan all the rituals all the demon
sacrifices all the weird drawings and
all the sucking on those boys nips I
know you were Satan I knew it anyway
how's it gonna raise my spirit back
welcome back to forest ah
the hills are alive with the sound of
chopping meat ah food plain food I don't
care if I'm starving not eating plain
food is that a leg tickle tickle
oh what a lovely place to crash this is
wonderful chocolate chocolate hello
everyone just packs a bar of chocolate
it's amazing
let's see a page are you doing good to
be back man it's good to be back all
right let's I never read the notes on
the new buildable treehouse the [ __ ]
does that mean
tree house [ __ ] tree houses how does
that even work
I don't care let's build it there that
BB oh god we need 35 Hey
alright we're just gonna have to power
through oh I can I'm wearing the Lizzie
Armour oh this is quite exhausting work
good thing I have this Lucy sweat band
it's the highest fashion to wear the lid
ah Jesus that's two out of 35 all right
this is like a candlestick
you shall not stick oh oh oh I got him
oh he did oh hey Jesus Christ don't look
at me like that
Oh God then I kill the godly seagull
well that's just too bad
Oh God oh god they're here
Oh God they know they know I killed
sticky stupid tree did you write me out
stupid tree
Oh God they see me seagull what are you
doing in my inventory
ah he's distracting mate wedding Lizzy
you can't touch me
my Lizzy sweatband it was all for
nothing
oh god I better read oh I'm running joke
hear me Shannon get Shannon she's she
may be drunk but she's filled with
protein when you can't get it you try to
see him here go Shannon go tell the king
and come back with his men
wait wait deflects Gilligan you baby a
dude you drunk son of a [ __ ] Shannon it
worked
what stabbed goodbye but have a good
life yes chopping down the trees slower
that's what everyone requested in the
end new updates let's see what the [ __ ]
Lacey ah what were you thinking it looks
funny oh god is he gonna do it again now
you're just going through the tree this
time aren't you oh god you're doing what
the [ __ ] late day what is stakes on the
wiki page stop this nonsense you know
what if you're a wizard that I'm a
[ __ ] warlock
you shall not list up come up heads no
I'm stuck though can we please laughs
stupid Lacey think you can tell me what
to do my spinach is [ __ ] tree house
oh my god
he's pooping out this is quite the rare
sight some say it's a miracle to see
turtle this far from land
I say it's turtle soup Lacey stop this
nonsense
oh god I paid to get me out I am
hey I just need one more tree one more
tree and we can sleep oh god no not now
please
oh god oh god they're everywhere finish
the house lemon
ah this place is amazing like I have a
window um yeah that's all I got really
but it's amazing this place the [ __ ] are
they doing
you should running in circles look at
that [ __ ]
what are you doing I hope that's working
out for you
you look really look really good
seriously look in my Lizzie armor it's
amazing [ __ ] high fashion fashion
fashion it's Lizzie Prada it's Lana it's
la-de-da-de-da god I love these baby
seals sake on sake ah ah you're not cute
[ __ ] she can hurt us now oh my god so
much chocolate I love it like infinite
supply of chocolate there
Who am I kidding that's like five
minutes of chocolate they already
started with Christmas decoration at
this place I don't like that it's
September god dammit don't get ahead of
yourself
hi mate how you doing are you perhaps
looking for your deck
Slappy's boutique oh god he's jealous
he's jealous maybe you wouldn't be
jealous if you were so insecure did we
actually find a way out whoa oh my god
it's morning hey we're free wait did it
yes are alive by the sound of chopping
where's the but where's the butter I'm
only four after the but goodbye but live
long and prosper but that won't happen
to my axe
oh my god I'm bro fisting them now it's
amazing look at this bro fest it's
amazingly strong just like my town what
is in these boxes
metal gear some [ __ ]
I'm using you as a shield he'll never
see me how Gotti spotted me now go box
go I'm pretty badass chopping down trees
with my bare hands what is this
minecraft all right we have two amazing
little traps would you do me a favor and
come here darling darling looks like
I'll need your charm Lizzie if that my
skin hurts
are you seriously just doing that nah
it's fake its fake I swear ha you were
fake you skank all right come here babe
come here babe
let me touch your boobs come on let me
touch them oh oh it's not working Lizzie
yeah Devon it never works when I want to
touch your boobs Oh guys she's coming
Ron I almost there
just come here stupid [ __ ] ha ha oh the
boyfriend - the boyfriend - what is he
doing to my tree that's my tree house me
[ __ ] come back here chop his ass off
that's what I did I know you shave your
ass and everything but that isn't me you
can show it off it's time for legs to
see if you will live or if you will die
like I spared your life
haters gonna hate hate hate hate hate
I'm just gonna shake shake shake shake
shake I'm gonna keep you there for a
while so you can think about what you
did let God spared your life leg likes
you so pretty so pretty
kisses nails kiss legs nails it's time
for my 360 MLG noscope montage to begin
ooh ah ok that didn't really go well
alright now just stay still now for one
second I'm gonna try to hit you in the
nuts hey that hurt
see dad now oh is that oh wow why did I
leave that stupid space in the middle
Oh gotcha [ __ ] ha ha it's just you me
and that sweet sweet ass it's a party in
the USA yeah what is happening with the
ropes man what is pulling him so much
over there ha ha ha look at that what
are you doing what are you trying to do
[ __ ] what the hell are you guys trying
to do what is he/she trying to escape
God um oh I actually got him damn I'm
good I don't know this guy just packs a
lot of heat oh nice eh yes
it pains me to do this but I need to
know if you're the chosen one that I
asks it's holy ah yes
smack that booty yes yes [ __ ] yes oh I
can smack that podium much I like
smacking booty with a leg this is the
best gameplay of 2014 my god I've never
been so immersed no no no no no oh no it
was my only friend it's been a long
night but we're gonna have to end that
up so there the frozen George go ahead
and hit that like button and it supports
the show and lets me know you want more
and that's all for me for now a lot of a
lot of fun playing Wii Bros as always
stay awesome rivers I know you